[Música]
los humanos nos diferenciamos del resto
de animales por dos sencillas razones
una en la capacidad que tenemos de
colaborar y cooperar de manera flexible
y en números grandes de personas la otra
diferencia principal es la capacidad que
tenemos de imaginar proyectar mundos que
no existen crear historias crear sueños
quiero que cierren los ojos
cuál es el sueño de tu ciudad
con qué personas se relacionan qué
actividades hace
cómo se sienten
traten de llevarse a ese momento y
encontrar todos sus puntos
esa misma pregunta me la hice yo y no
sabía ni por dónde empezar dije bueno
voy a empezar por los conceptos la raíz
los romanos llamaban la químicas la
químicas es la asociación de personas
libres personas que colaboran que
intercambian que viven sus sueños en
este ecosistema de vida
las unidades son mucho más que edificios
construcciones infraestructura puentes
las ciudades van mucho más profundo van
a la mera esencia humana a ese
intercambio libre donde las personas
puede interactuar y conocerse
y es que la ciudad está viva está viva
porque sus sueños mis sueños nuestros
sueños alimentan este ecosistema es un
reflejo de la sociedad
me puse a pensar si es un reflejo de la
sociedad como podio como persona empezar
a impactar positivamente mi entorno
yo nací y crecí en este lugar es un
plano visto desde arriba pero yo crecí
en esa colonia y me di cuenta que había
muchas posibilidades desde su inicio que
habían diseñado un bulevar que ha
diseñado banquetas un montón de
posibilidades pero que al final nunca se
llevaron a cabo en su totalidad
esto es lo que yo veo hoy no hay
banquetas basura un montón de problemas
que pareciera que a la gente no le
importa
me volví obsesivo con el tema de las
baquetas y empecé a fijarme en todas
partes de la ciudad donde no hay
banquetas donde la infraestructura cómo
afecta el espacio físico a las personas
cómo se relacionan
y específicamente me di cuenta de que
también nos hacía falta de espacios de
convivencia áreas verdes áreas donde
pudiéramos compartir con mis vecinos me
di cuenta que donde vivía había un
sector que estaba determinado para ser
un parque de 10 manzanas y que yo ni
enterado me enteré hace dos años y
existía cuando llevaba toda mi vida
viviendo ahí
y esta gran mancha verde esta delicia de
naturaleza estaba justo al lado de
nuestras casas y mi cuenta nos había
montado con ríos ecosistemas virtuosos
diversos
y es que con un grupo de visionarios y
vecinos empezamos a pensar cómo podemos
recuperar este espacio que había sido
abandonado olvidado por las personas y
darle esta esencia esta esencia de
jungla urbana que es una selva inmersa
en nuestra ciudad
generamos ideas posibilidades qué tal si
hay un huerto comunitario qué tal si hay
columpios áreas de estar áreas para
hacer picnic senderismo cuántas ideas
arte todos estos sueños los pusimos de
esta manera para poder proyectar un
sueño y que las personas que vivían en
este espacio se dieran cuenta de las
posibilidades que existían
y es que con este grupo de visionarios y
locos nos emprendimos a hacer también un
vídeo que exponía las problemáticas y
las oportunidades de los barrancos en la
ciudad los barrancos con contemplan el
42 por ciento del territorio del
municipio de guatemala imagínense la
oportunidad con este vídeo nos vamos a
roma donde tenemos la oportunidad de
compartir nuestras experiencias y sueños
con una comunidad global de
emprendedores por el espacio público
a esto cuando regresamos a guatemala
mucha gente se quería sumar quería
apoyar y dijimos cómo podemos hacer que
todas estas personas se quiera apoyar se
sumen y se empezó a construir un
movimiento que hoy le llamamos va
arrancando que la acción de bajar al
barranco para rankear es explorar tu
ciudad para rankear es conocer a tu
vecino para rankear es darse la libertad
de vivir en nuestro ecosistema
y como ven el trayecto de la ciudad de
guatemala está inmenso en naturaleza
tenemos volcanes tenemos lagos estamos
interconectados por barrancos los 17
municipios que están conformando el
departamento de guatemala tienen
atributos naturales y muchos de ellos
tienen barrancos que nos conectan las
barreras políticas no cumplen esa
función
nos dimos cuenta de cómo podemos empezar
a hacer las ciudades más amigables para
las personas tomando como punto de
partida este experimento que habíamos
hecho y descubrimos de que hubiera
metodología que ya existía y se llama
urbanismo táctico el urbanismo táctico
es la base del emprendimiento ensayo y
error construimos medimos y aprendemos
por esos rápidos fáciles donde podemos
darnos la oportunidad de tomar riesgos
pedimos tiempo tener muchísimo que ganar
esta metodología consta de
intervenciones de corto plazo que tienen
incidencia en el largo plazo es algo muy
ligero muy barato con poco riesgo puede
tener un impacto muy positivo en el
futuro
como por ejemplo algo tan sencillo como
poner mesas en el barranco e invitar a
todos los vecinos que tienen calentarse
por el barranco a compartir a compartir
una comida la esencia de la humanidad de
poder simplemente conocernos - a los
ojos y darnos cuenta que hay mucho más
que nos une y es este espacio el que se
presta para este tipo de convivencia
sencillo barato como por ejemplo hacemos
un anfiteatro con tierra apelmazada con
obra de construcción los residuos que
quedan a la construcción invita a la
gente a participar este caso era un un
concierto de un coro de niños que podían
transmitir sus ideas en espacio libre si
tiene que pagar nada generar rutas
ecológicas que los niños exploren los
barrancos no se imagina la cantidad de
niños que hemos llevado que no tiene ni
idea de lo que es un barranco y cuando
llegan se quedan atónitos de la belleza
natural que existe
como muros olvidados sectores que
estaban considerados como perdidos como
abandonados se pueden recuperar con la
integración de las personas personas de
diferentes edades de diferentes
intereses se juntan en un punto para
hacer realidad sus sueños
en este caso estábamos pintando todo el
catálogo de aves que habitan en el
barranco
hoy se ve así un espacio que en su
momento era considerado como muy
peligroso o un estimado negativo hoy
tiene un estigma positivo por toda la
experiencia que vivieron en ese momento
o como por ejemplo podemos dignificar
los ingresos al barranco a este parque
habían tres ingresos principales y
únicamente uno está habilitado y aún así
daba miedo a la entrada como los vecinos
se apoderan en este espacio y empiezan a
darle vida a darle color a experimentar
ese es el ingreso actual donde toda la
biodiversidad se expone para que la
gente se sienta bienvenida y que
participe en estos lugares de encuentro
como una acción tan liviana como hacer
una limpieza participativa reciclaje
participativo nos puede enseñar a cómo
manejar nuestros desechos de manera
sostenible actualmente el 95% de
nuestros ríos están contaminados y el
foco más importante es la ciudad la
mayoría de nuestros desagües y drenajes
paran en los ríos cómo podemos empezar a
evidenciar esta problemática pero
también evidenciar las oportunidades que
tenemos como sociedad como ciudad
estos tres niños vivían en asentamiento
que estaba dentro del barranco muchas de
las actividades que ellos aprenden desde
pequeño es talar el árbol para poder
generar energía poder comer
qué pasa si generamos nuevas
herramientas para que los para que los
niños formen parte de la solución estos
niños antes mataban los pájaros con
piedras y ahora tienen la habilidad de
tener un mecanismo que le dice qué tipo
de aves
van a buscar el pájaro lo marcan y luego
comparte sus hallazgos y aprendizajes
como una herramienta tan sencilla puede
cambiar completamente el comportamiento
de una persona y todo lo que hacemos
tiene también herramientas de medición
en este caso aplicamos también en la
carta ciudadana que empuja los cambios
que necesitamos en temas de saneamiento
de agua específicamente empuja el
decreto 232 2006 que regula los desechos
y descargas que tenemos hacia los ríos
en los ciudadanos estén conscientes de
que existe este acuerdo y que lo empujen
para que se cumpla
generamos también otros sistemas de
medición más de 600 encuestas 300
encuestas antes y 30 encuestas después
para saber cómo había afectado la
intervención en la actividad de las
personas nos dimos cuenta que para las
personas era sumamente importante los
barrancos y aumenta la hora que tenemos
las intervenciones y también preguntamos
por qué son importantes los barrancos y
mucha gente nos dijo porque limpian y
captan limpian el aire captan el agua
qué actividades te gustaría hacer entre
los barrancos deportes senderismo
actividades culturales la misma gente es
la que opina y forma parte de esta
construcción de ciudad
qué es lo que te gusta de los barrancos
nos dimos cuenta que a la gente le
apasionaba la naturaleza la tranquilidad
su belleza escénica
qué es lo que no te gusta de los
barrancos y respeta que la basura a la
contaminación la delincuencia eran
puntos importantes pero el principal es
la basura entonces lo que nos sirve
también esas herramientas de que
evidencia la realidad y lo que las
personas piensan de un tema y no solo un
imaginario que a veces creemos que de
cierto
nos dimos cuenta que los accesos a dos
barrancos también eran complicados que
no estaban señalizados y la imagen que
no lo dijo que era muy difícil conocer
los accesos y poder identificarlos
algo tan sencillo como confiar en tu
vecino es algo que hemos perdido en
ciudades que se han basado únicamente en
crecimiento por el carro y que nos hemos
olvidado de caminar por nuestras calles
y nos damos cuenta que con las
intervenciones que hacemos aumentan
también los niveles de confianza
acciones rápidas sencillas que tienen
impacto en el largo plazo
ahora bien les preguntamos a las
personas como sueñan los barrancos y
también les pregunto a ustedes como
sueñan los barrancos
libre de contaminación como haga
recreativas seguros como eres naturales
qué es para ti para arrancar
conectarse idiota de naturaleza una
aventura explorar compartir con otros
desconectarse del caos urbano
y es que estos experimentos solo han
venido a evidenciar que los humanos
podemos crear nuevos mundos podemos
imaginar nuevas formas de vida los
barrancos tienen gran parte de nuestra
actividad y depende de nosotros el uso y
la vocación que le querramos dar
qué tal si hoy se pueden a pensar en su
entorno donde viven y qué pueden hacer
ustedes como ciudadanos libres para
mejorar su entorno conectarse con sus
vecinos y empezar a generar propuestas
los invito a que toquen el timbre de su
vez y no encuentren problemas en la
colonia y se involucren en hacer ciudad
porque la ciudad somos todos
muchas gracias
[Música]